uh let's try another international call
let's go to syed from bangladesh syed
you're on the air oh
hello uh thank you for you know actually
uh selecting me i have been you know
like trying to get on your call for a
few i'd say weeks i guess
my pleasure
so okay
uh uh
the the thing i'm going to ask you it's
not really you know like it's sort of
you know your opinion i would really
like to you know like uh you know know
what you feel about this so hear me out
so
as you can you know like uh completely
yes i am not from america right but i
can you know like in a lot of you know
like because of a lot of international
you know issues and stuff we end up you
know like listening to our you know
american politics and you know like
basically international involvements and
basically so
during this you know like pandemic and
you know the other stuff when i had you
know much more you know like time to
actually you know look through all of
the stuff i have noticed something you
know like very
i would say surprising in you know let's
say in america right now
so hear me out on this one uh currently
i can see that you know most of the
people who are you know let's say
they're right-wingers you know they're
religious and whatnot
and they are basically you know like
trying to you know like uh
they have their own set of ideologies
let's say and left have their own set of
ideologies and right now
let's see the muslim populations in the
west they are kind of you know like
in a scenario where they sort of feel
like they are in some kind of you know
political homelessness that is something
that i'm going to say
so let's say you know like uh
someone is you know like a practicing
you know muslim let's say and you know
he wants to you know
basically follow you know like
traditional stuff and do religious or
worshiping and other stuff like that and
you know
basically a person like that you know
oftentimes you know like doesn't get
along with you know let's say you know
insanely
someone who is you know like a very
hardcore lefty right and then you have
you know on the other side the right
wingers who are actually you know like
they claim to be religious and you know
they are you know practitioners of
mostly christianity and then they have
problems with you know muslims right so
i have seen this you know scenario where
like muslims feeling in like political
homelessness and like any kind of
i'd say you know like uh the right wing
people i would say that you know
they are basically shooting themselves
in their foot you know when they are you
know doing all this you know like let's
say some sort of anti-muslim stuff yeah
and you know and then they're wondering
yeah why are we losing
right
i think it's a very astute point so if
you consider the religious muslim
community
you have folks who
culturally
are really more in line with the
religious christian community often in
terms of
the role they want to see religion play
in civil government in terms of cultural
norms in terms of social norms but
republicans in the united states they
are like that only with regard to
christianity and sometimes they'll
pretend with judaism as well although
really they're often anti-semitic but
there's a there's more i know i know
so
that's really where the muslims would
would find a cultural social home but
the republicans don't want them and then
on the left
those very same religious muslims would
often say oh these folks want secularism
that's not what i want either and it
leaves these folks sort of out out in a
no man's land i think it's a very astute
analysis and i think you're completely
right syed
i think it is going to like
let me explain a scenario like i'm gonna
uh
we'll say it i have so many people
holding i'm gonna let you go now because
we we've done i think we've done a good
amount today but call back okay but i
love the point you made
okay okay very good all right syed from
bangladesh extraordinarily good point
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because i'm going
right back to the phones in a moment